alright so I got some good news for you
guys great news really after months upon
months of meaning to do it I finally
launched jeremyjahns calm and the reason
I did this is because there's so much to
talk about in the world and there's not
enough time in the world to make a video
talking about all of it and so on Jeremy
Jahns calm I will have my blog where I
will talk about more [ __ ] i'm sure you
have a couple questions like are you
gonna make less videos now good question
you look great today by the way i try no
i'm not gonna make less videos but in
the off time of videos there's still
stuff to talk about that's where my blog
is gonna come in i will blog about [ __ ]
and hopefully you'll laugh not actually
[ __ ] and stuff alright so what are the
blog is gonna be like actually question
my friend and i shall answer it's gonna
be like this is gonna be like me talking
like i have a couple of blogs up right
now if you go to it you'll see i type
how I talk so when you read it you're
like hey Jeremy wrote that hopefully see
that anyway and like my videos I like
being short and sweet because when you
see a blog like this you're like [ __ ]
read that so some short reads and sweet
laughs and abundance and frequently
that's the goal of the blog the blog's
name is awesome tacular also i might
change it later on but I like calling my
blog awesome tacular yes Jeremy Jahns
com the blog is awesome tacular but what
will you talk about in your blogs like
nudes and movies news and games news in
the world just whatever I find awesome
tacular whatever I think you'll find
awesome tag you there too so it's like a
win-win for everybody it's fun to write
it's fun to read I'll bring you some fun
sweet content there and I'll keep the
video content coming here just as
frequent as I've ever done so it's like
a win win win win quadruple win I don't
know how mathematically is quadruple
wind I think it sounded awesome so go to
ww jeremyjahns com I guess you have to
put the www in front of it otherwise it
tasted like GoDaddy or something I put
the link in the underbar below where you
can go to my main page and click on my
name on the top couple different ways to
get there so please subscribe to my blog
follow my blog you won't regret it
promise and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you